[Music]
okay everyone so this is my spoiler
review of mike flanagan's newest show
midnight mass if you haven't watched the
show yet watch my spoiler free review
which is also on the channel which will
be linked down below as well and also
i'll be going into detail about every
single episode here but the thing is
cannot watch this review until you've
seen the whole season because i'm going
to be connecting dots from stuff that
happens in the first episode that
connects to stuff that is in the finale
so make sure you watch the full season
first before you watch any of this
review that is your final warning i'm
going to do things a little differently
where with blind manor when i reviewed
each episode i gave a score for the
episode then i gave a score for how
scary it was this show is kind of
showing flanagan's not in the business
of as much horror anymore and i think
that's coming to be accepted now so i'm
not gonna do that this time i'm gonna do
a rating for when i first watched the
episode and then my rating for the
second watch of each episode because i
feel like what he has developed himself
as with all of his shows is they demand
two watches to really understand
everything and appreciate it and that's
for better or for worse meaning if
you're someone who has the time to do
that and appreciates that great you
probably love it and i can understand
frustrations by people who just want to
enjoy a show on their first watch where
you feel like you're kind of suffering
through it so let's jump into it i have
a lot of thoughts here so what was
interesting about midnight mass compared
to blind manor like haunted field house
mike flanagan is directing every single
episode here so my expectations were
through the roof i know what this man
can do he is incredible at what he does
and i was excited to see what he was
going to bring to the table here so with
this show when we as critics got the
screeners for it there's always a nice
screener letter that comes with the show
that mike flanagan always writes and
kind of pours his heart out about the
show and i always read it after because
i don't want to to impair my judgment
about anything and what's interesting is
that he mentions that he was an altar
boy growing up he was catholic and you
see that this is a very personal tale
from him and as someone as myself who
also grew up catholic he really will
nail through the show how catholic mass
works
the things they say in mass the whole
culture behind it it's totally accurate
it's like 100 detail and what you have
to understand watching this show is that
this really is like mike flanagan's true
beliefs about faith but also it's like
the book of mike flanagan the way they
angle the episode titles being after
bible chapters and also that you're
getting the book of flanagan and i'll
break down why i think that and why this
is like his own version of the bible so
episode one is titled book one genesis
this episode is directed and written by
mike flanagan himself i love how he
opens this show that we see the most
critical moment in our main character's
life of riley which happened four years
earlier than present day in the show and
this is his life-changing moment when he
killed a woman from drunk driving and
what i liked about this which made it
fresh is that it does the opposite with
stories like this where usually the
character's finding faith in prison and
they highlight that it's the opposite
effect for riley where he loses his
faith and we see that he puts away the
bible what i love about the horror that
flanagan did have in this episode and it
reminded me a lot of stuff he did in
hill house was the effect we'll see
throughout when riley sees the girl he
killed and when he sees visions of her i
love he had the glass in her head and
the police lights flickering on her so
that you could show the effect from
riley's point of view and then when you
see riley seeing it you see the lights
flicker on him i thought it was such a
nice touch and very cool and it's again
just delving you down to riley's guilt
and how this will plague him for the
rest of his life so when we get to
crockett island this small island with a
population of 127 people what he's doing
here flanagan is setting up all of these
characters for us to know all their
ailments so that goes from lisa can't
walk you know the dad has a bad back the
mom can barely see and it sets up also
stuff that we see is good here but we'll
have tragic outcomes like what's
happening with our main character aaron
played by kate siegel but it all will be
something that's affected by this
vampire demon blood that will change
everything to happen here on the island
so when you're doing a re-watch of this
show already in episode one there's so
many hints at what's going to happen
flanagan left you so many clues here so
it's really fun to watch and kind of see
things that he put literally right in
front of your face the first moment i
noticed this was when the brother warren
is waiting for his brother riley to come
off the boat and come back home what you
see is when riley gets off the boat
behind him you see father peter come off
almost like he's an extra in the show
and he has the trunk with the demon
angel in it so i thought that was really
interesting that he kind of showed you
your your main antagonist here and it's
just kind of acted like it's nothing and
a couple scenes later we're only seeing
the back of father paul's head here
right like when he's bringing in this
trunk to his house so flanagan is doing
a good job of teasing you about this
mysterious character we're gonna learn
about and he's banging on the trunk so
you know something's in there because it
bangs back so just nice little touches
to get you intrigued and i love even in
a scene like this there's this eerie
choral music that plays throughout the
show my favorite thing about this show
compared to blind manner in haunting
house and i know it's tough to say
compared to haunting philos which also
had a great score this was my favorite
score they have done yet i thought it
was masterful because it set the tone so
well being that it's a show taking place
mostly in mass having the choral music
set the tone in so many scenes so well
and it was really beautiful music too so
props to that and there's these lines
that were kind of throwaway lines you'll
see in the first episode but on rewatch
they're not throwaway lines at all like
when the three boys including warren he
goes with his friends out to the upwards
on this separate island one of the boys
says right away did you see that monster
pelican huge wingspan talking about this
you know demon vampire and when he was
already there he landed on this island
and you see others set up and
foreshadowing warns telling a story to
the other boys that everything from the
upwards where they're on washes up onto
the shore of the west bank by my house
this is setting up the stray cats to
wash up to the shore and what is
interesting is i love how flannigan
shoots these scenes where you got the
stray cat's eyes just appearing here and
there i thought that was really cool and
you get your first glimp of the demon
vampire when warren puts his flashlight
on him real quick so again nice touch
and again we're talking about lines that
seemed like insignificant at first but
the second watch is more as you see when
we meet joe he's being held in jail by
the sheriff hassan you see that joe says
when he was drunk that the night before
he had said that he had saw a giant
albatross and the wings as big as lawn
chairs again he wasn't seeing things it
sounds like it but he wasn't it was this
demon and you know joe says it makes
sense because albatraz means bad luck so
again this also does two things at
setting up not just the demon but that
these birds these seagulls the albatross
is bad luck and that's gonna come to the
beach in full form when those stray cats
are on the beach so again it's just
beautifully setting things up and
foreshadowing and then right after we
get a scene where joe's dog barks at
beverly really our main villain here and
you know she claims he snapped at her
and it goes back to that feeling where
dogs just have a sense of bad people bad
vibes and you could see right away that
dog was having nothing to do with
beverly and it sets up nicely her
poisoning this dog and her hate for joe
in general i also like how flanigan sets
up certain character relationships just
with quick images literally like riley
and prison looking at old photos it's
setting up his relationship with his
family but also aaron and he does that
again here when you see the bedroom
images of people important to him in
this past that will be maine to his
story so i like that he kind of plants
little images in your head that's even
just with him having pictures with
mountain senior pruitt as a kid that
this is going to be an important
character here's a question for you guys
maybe you guys can answer this i noticed
with the signage here in the town in
front of the church they didn't use
capital a's they replaced them with
fours i don't know if this was for a a
or something else
what is that why is that significant i'd
love to see any of you guys who are
really good at analyzing that stuff kind
of come up with your theories of why
they never used a capital a
in this show on the sign i think they
did maybe once but mostly it's used as
the number four now where things can get
a little confusing is when exactly bev
realized that father paul was pruitt and
you thought maybe it was here because
she sees the trunk unlocked and sees the
young pruitt but she doesn't recognize
him yet and the reason i know that is
because there's a moment that it's very
sly how flanigan does it but it comes up
i'm pretty sure in two or three which
i'll get to in an exact moment which if
you look at it again is made clear when
she realizes this but it's not here also
little things that are really important
right that scene where riley's with his
father and ed says he doesn't want him
taking communion because it stopped him
and this is important because this is
essential to riley's character that he
doesn't drink the blood here so that is
why riley hasn't getting these side
effects from drinking the blood that
everyone else is by doing communion so i
thought that was really cool how they
kind of blended that in and set that up
now what was some of my favorite imagery
and stuff working really well
thematically here was when riley would
have his recurring dream or you call it
nightmare where he's on this boat he's
stuck in his guilt and he's not seeing
the sun rise but it's great because in
this sequence his first night home he
sees the girl again that he killed but
in his boat we get a flash of the bloody
church cut in from the last episode
really quickly so it's actually showing
you the massacre that's going to happen
which is pretty cool i love when
directors do that and he's stuck in this
darkness and guilt focusing sitting out
on the boat but the dream ends where the
next shot cuts to sunrise foreshadowing
when he will heal and pass and they do
this again later on but adding in that
dream aaron's character so again they
brilliantly kind of give that little
hope that he will get at the end of this
story and again little things right like
this first mass here where warren the
altar boy with the other altar boy
notices really quick like oh the crew
it's already filled with wine someone
already did it so you know it that's
where it began that's when this father
paul came to town started replacing the
wine with the vampire blood so when
father paul here makes his first
appearance at the church it is hamish
linklater right away he has that special
power as an actor where he is a presence
in this show i truly believe that if
we're gonna take the best out of this
show it's whenever he was on the screen
and like i was saying about when you're
seeing how this mass is happening
perfect detail of catholic mass if
you've ever been one it is to a t the
music the vibes the ceremony how they're
reacting everything the priest is saying
but it's also the performance of the
priest by hamish linklater here which is
masterful he reminds me of so many
priests i knew growing up and this is
where father paul tells his big lie here
that pruitt fell ill and is recovering
in a hospital and they do a good job
right now at this point of hiding the
real choice that he is actually
monsignor pruitt and it's so fascinating
on second watch because when you realize
that when he's outside father paul and
he's introducing himself to everybody he
already knows everybody you know being
pruitt and he took note of riley not
taking communion because he wants that
blood in him he wants in everybody and
he also recognizes riley because he knew
him as a boy and there's some great
foreshadowing here between father paul
and riley because paul says you know
jesus kept the people who were
non-believers the closest to him and he
called them friends this is
foreshadowing the relationship that paul
will have with riley in this show and
that paul sees himself as a jesus figure
in this story which is very important to
his character but that he's gonna see
himself as like saving someone like
riley someone who he sees as lost so
this is where i'm praising everything so
far but now i'm gonna go to the stuff of
flanagan i don't like that first shows
up here and you'll see it a lot in this
show but it's classic flanagan way too
long of a scene where we're seeing riley
and aaron catching up about life right
walking through the town and it's just
too long you need to tighten these up i
get that he has a purpose for all these
type of scenes but there's got to be
more interesting way to convey this
information than just watching two
people walk around to town in one take
for so damn long
i think flanagan again he's one of those
directors i had said in my blind manner
review when i listened to his commentary
of hill house he was always saying
things like ah i wish i didn't cut this
part out and that's like no i'm happy
you did like i think he over invests
into his stuff too many times that
sometimes i feel like he's not listening
to maybe another ear he needs whether
it's an editor or somebody else telling
him like tighten this up you know like
don't get so invested by your own eyes
watching it i feel like he does that i
feel like he's not listening to someone
else from an outsider perspective
because these kind of scenes are what
start to really zone people out now i
like this moment here where bev says to
paul he should be wearing the green
chalice because it's an ordinary sunday
he's like no i wore the gold i forgot
you know but we know the payoff later on
that he didn't forget it was not an
ordinary sunday this was the sunday
where he was going to start but he
believed his miracle and giving people
this blood so during this huge storm
that hits the town you see riley notices
he thinks it's monsignor pruitt out on
the beach because it's his clothing but
that's really the demon vampire that is
on the beach and that was pretty cool
that gave that flanagan horror that i
really like remind me of hillhouse
seeing this tall mysterious figure from
afar and again what was set up next
morning you see the stray cats on the
beach you see the albatross bad luck so
we know something bad is happening here
something evil is here and it's feeding
on these dead stray cats which obviously
was this demon vampire so first watch
this is the thing that's bittersweet
about mike flanagan because for me on
first watch i only gave this a 7.3
because i'm not noticing all this stuff
it's setting up it's kind of feeling
like everything's a throwaway line
second watch so i'm giving it a full
point up at 8.3 where
it was way more enjoyable because then
you're like ah like you're catching
everything you see the deepness to it so
again it's bittersweet and i get both
sides of the argument where why isn't
this better on first watch you know how
many people have time to rewatch i don't
know and then i have time to watch so i
still appreciate it but i get both sides
i'm not gonna say which is a better way
to go about making a show but that's
what i feel that second watch is way
better okay so episode two is titled
book two psalms this one is directed by
mike flanagan like they all are but he
is also writing this but bringing his
brother james flanagan who's wrote in a
lot of black manner episodes also very
talented and elon gale so we got three
writers on this so my least favorite
scene and stretch of the show is classic
example again where i i think this is
the achilles heel of mike flanagan where
it becomes a little drawn out and
pretentious was this opening scene in
episode two where it's one take right
he's got the handheld camera on this on
the beach but everybody is just talking
and talking about what happened that we
clearly see just tighten it up you know
you're developing certain characters
like the mayor here but my god this was
way over long and it was too to the
point of some people who are in cinema
just google over this stuff like wow he
did this one take with the birds flying
around the cats but at the end of the
day it's boring it's just boring it's so
long so really just a momentum killer
here i did not like it i didn't like it
on first watch i also didn't like it on
the second watch because i don't think
it had much meat to it so we get our
biggest hint right out of the gate here
when father paul visits what we now know
his daughter sarah and his lover milly
and knowing who they really are it's
funny hearing sarah call him father
because he is father paul but we really
know it means something else the other
day which is just crazy and then millie
sees him and goes john so she recognizes
him sarah says she thinks you're
monsignor pruitt this was your biggest
hint they're literally saying it so you
know millie you're looking at her
through her dementia like oh like sarah
is like she doesn't know what she's
talking about but she's actually right
here and that wasn't just a coincidence
like that's him and the other big hint
honestly but he won't catch her on first
watch unless you're really like looking
for everything but the look of love that
pruitt gives millie when he first sees
her which was again just an attribute to
a great acting performance here all
around by amish link leader just so good
at those little things and on re-watch
there's little details that are quick to
catch but are great like you know when
riley's mom annie is sewing she nicks
her finger and she knows her vision
coming back looking at the bleeding so
again we're seeing now the effects of
the blood they just drank and their
ailments going away slowly and then
flanagan also sneaks in a really cool
point of view drone like shot at night
of the point of view of the demon flying
to the island and landing in the shed
which will eventually kill the poor drug
dealer bull that was crazy because on
first watch you don't know really what
that perspective is that you're seeing
why am i seeing this drone shot on town
now you know on second watch you're just
getting a view from this demon vampire
so what's crazy is you're gonna get this
crazy foreshadowing monologue here
that's amazing it's on the mass for ash
wednesday here because what father paul
is talking about is this island
resurrection that will happen like
easter will rise even out of sin love
will rise again funny because this is
true of this tale as well and he says in
the absence of light and hope we sing
this is a line that in mike flanagan's
screener letter to critics he
highlighted at the end of his letter
saying in the absence of
hope we sing this is the whole big
message he's talking about that's a very
flannigan-esque theme of hope here
because we literally see this scene
later when everyone's singing on the end
of the island during the darkness when
they're about to all die so
really just set up so well and he says
father paul that same hand that dealt
you your hardship the same hand will
make you whole again true to this
everyone the characters in this story
that all this hell they go through is
making them whole at the end of the day
and then when he's putting ashes on
everyone's forehead just like the prayer
is in church fresh wednesday remember
your dust and to dust your shower turn
again this is visually seen where
everyone goes to dusty of this story but
also it sets up the note that riley will
write to father paul and
say that to him and that pisses off
pruitt at the end of the day so i i
really love how that worked out and that
how was so planned well how important
that monologue is oh and if you want to
go big hints about this being monsignor
pruitt you're just gonna laugh yourself
re-watching this how you didn't catch it
cause he's really giving you huge hints
like when sarah is on this date with a
fellow woman and she's making the point
like you know father paul is just
staring at me and she says wow you know
our old monsignor would stare at me just
like that so that was another huge hint
that it was pruitt i love that so
what's also crazy is at this crock pot
luck you get the quickest shot of
beverly's feet passing joe's dog and
dropping the poisoned hot dog for joe's
dog so it's confirmed it's her and again
she wanted him to suffer she never liked
him for what he did to lisa and also
again the dog just barking at her she
doesn't like joe period and she actually
wants to poison his dog bev is an awful
person and it's interesting too because
erin was the one who confronted her
about the poison in her closet and
aaron's eyes light up at bev when this
happens because you know she knows it
had to be her poisonous dog and i'm sure
that's why she approached the sheriff
about this because the sheriff will
indirectly accuse bev of poisonous dog
and in that scene when the sheriff's
accusing her and i love flanagan uses
this great like camera work to make it
so off-putting just seeing beverly here
when she's lying to the sheriff but it's
a tribute to one of my other favorite
performances in this show clearly is
samantha sloan who has been in haunting
of hill house but this really was the
performance that flanagan gave her to
shine she is incredible and when i was
talking about how i love how flanagan
used the music here the choral music in
particular to set moods and scenes i
love that he's using the cheerful choral
music when stuff starts going good for
certain characters like riley starts
doing better and helping his dad at work
but also in that moment his dad's back
is getting better so it's a nice touch
okay so the first real meaty scene of
this show and again is his flanagan at
his best where he's getting amazing
performances out of his actors with some
incredible writing underneath it and
there's this two-person aaa meeting in
the rec center between riley and paul
and to me riley's character has to be
written from a place of mike flanagan
like that flanagan is basing this
character off of at least his belief
system like when riley's talking to paul
it feels like it's a dialogue of
flanagan to his beliefs about religion i
can never say that for sure i'm not mike
flanagan but that's how i'm reading this
but at the end of the day riley's
talking and his thoughts really are
mostly the message of this show and he's
calling out bev you know for taking
money from the oil settlement and all
the hypocrisy the catholic church so
it's talking about themes like that and
it's crazy watching it on rewatch just
knowing that paul knows who riley is and
that he knew him as a boy and riley has
no idea who he's talking to here but
riley brings up rational recovery
instead of a a it's more about not being
powers but self-control it feels like
you're watching jack shepherd from lost
talk to john locke in these scenes
that's what i really appreciate about it
and how they have such a different view
about faith because paul the other day
is saying stuff like you know god can
take that pain and turn into something
good suffering has a reason which riley
doesn't see that and riley's almost mad
at god you know he's like god could end
suffering with a wave of hand but just
lets it happen worst part is that it
lets all the rest of us off the hook
because he's bringing up lisa and joe's
drinking and lisa being handicapped and
is like we can stand by saying god works
in mysterious ways and not do anything
about it it's like so that opposite of
self-responsibility and that riley's
saying that these people these religious
people are using these different bible
quotes and everything as an excuse to
not do more and take responsibility and
he's saying nothing good came out of my
drinking nothing good came out of me
killing that poor girl it's just a
realistic way of looking at things for
riley where paul doesn't see it that way
he sees that you know you have to have
faith that there is something good out
of it and that's the powerful line here
that riley says the only thing keeping
people doing nothing as ideas suffering
can be a gift from god so this was just
incredible performance here by zach
gilford who plays riley unbelievable so
so good and one of my favorite written
scenes and you'll see that they both get
a little blend by the end of this story
where riley does get in his own way a
universal faith in the stars and god
maybe however you want to call it and
paul obviously will come back down to
earth a bit by the end which we'll get
to and again flanagan you sneaky man
cause this scene with millie at night
she screams and she's like sarah come
quick i thought i saw your father i
thought it was your dad his clothes so
they're also giving me the hint that
again that this is pruitt and that he is
sarah's father they're giving you that
but she's really seeing again this demon
vampire in pruitt's clothes just like
riley did so the poor drug dealer named
bull gets mauled by this demon vampire
and i like that flanagan hasn't given us
a full vision of him yet at this point
and i wish flanagan did more of what he
does best with horror when he shows like
these figures in the dark you can't
really make out it's very scary to me
this was the scariest scene just seeing
not knowing what this figure was looking
at the camera and one of the best ending
scenes of the show happens in episode
two because it's such a good bow to
everything that was set up brilliantly
in this scene i was talking about the
meeting with riley and father paul and
you see that father paul almost feels
challenged now by riley and what riley
was saying so he's like you know what
i'm truly going to take a leap of faith
in his own plan here that he can take
the joke that it's already working this
blood on people and show his first
miracle for the doubters like riley and
he wants lisa to come up here and it's
such a hooking scene for the audience
here because it was set up so well but
it's huge for our main character riley
seeing this the guy who was doubting now
being shown on paper right visually if
you were there in other shoes it's a
miracle end of the day like how is this
happening so it was just an incredible
scene it was such an awesome way to end
the episode with her saying amen and
she's able to walk again so first watch
this was always good to me i think was
more enjoyable in the first episode 8.7
second watch it goes up a little 8.9
it's just a consistent down the road
both viewings a good solid episode so
episode three is titled book three
proverbs this is again directed by mike
flanagan of course but it's written by
mike and james flanagan so the brothers
write this one together so we open now
with father paul he's doing his
confession talking about the lies about
to tell us it's a little bit of a
flashback and then we get a super
flashback of we now know as pruitt who
is paul but pruitt's in jerusalem and
you see mike flanagan is now designed to
pull m night shyamalan where he's
appearing grabbing the old pruitt here
so he gets a nice little cameo i like it
hitchcock would do the same thing as
well so it's always a cool thing when
horror directors do that so
back to present day though right after
lisa's miracle we see how sick paul
really is in this episode through bev
and what i was talking about the moment
bev realizes who he is there's a moment
here towards the beginning's episode
where bev runs to the house to check on
him and she pauses and looks at the
image of young pruitt in the paper which
we only see from the paper's perspective
at her so we don't know what she's
looking at we will at the end of the
episode but this is where on rewatch you
realize at this point she made her
connection that she was with young
pruitt which could have been confusing
on first watch because you really kind
of like wait a minute when did she
realize this but on the second watch
it's rewarding it's really cool how like
flanagan snuck that in and flanagan's
just throwing in your face these hints
about him being pruitt at this point
there's literally a visual shot he does
in the house where father paul is
standing in line with the painting of
older pruitt it's like come on guys it's
right there and i didn't see it so i
shouldn't be on it anybody and you've
seen characters you know starting to
heal and you know millie's starting to
get these stares on her own she's
recognizing her own room and that it's
changed and he's reading without her
glasses and is dancing with no back pain
and i love
love the use of holly holy by neil
diamond here this was an awesome montage
setting up like this hopeful mode for
the town these miracles are happening
and riley's doing the steps in aaa lisa
and warren are kissing and this miracle
is just packing the church that happened
now faith is the hot thing in town but
in this hope and everything paul
collapses during mass he's getting
sicker and sicker here so it cuts back
to his confession and he talks about the
story in the bible saul becoming paul
where it happened on the same road he
wandered in jerusalem so that's why
another reason he picked the name paul
here and he was lost confused like saul
and he feels he's now paul of this story
so it's a connection he has to the
character of saul becoming poland that
he found this moment where god was
showing him the light when he became
young again what i loved about this was
while he's making his confession was
cutting between these sculpted paintings
you would see in a catholic church a lot
and they always show stories of the
bible and phases where a lot of times
it's the phases of the cross but in this
case you're seeing the phases of the
stories here of pruitt's miracle with
this he calls angel but it's like demons
fallen angel right and to me it's really
meta and cool because it's like is this
church we're seeing these sculpted
paintings in a separate church that
takes place after this story that tells
the story of pruitt like that something
lived on and continued this life under
this demon vampire
maybe but it's also me confirming that
again this is like the book of flanagan
this is his bible story and let's go
with another monsignor pruitt hint here
where sarah is actually treating pruitt
after he fell and pruitt says i'm proud
of you just randomly to her so it's like
okay there's your hand he's the father
so what's interesting here is lisa now
that she's walking she goes to visit joe
in his trailer and this is a great
moment and monologue by anara simone
it's just exciting great young talent
here flanagan has a great job of finding
young talent to kind of give them a lift
in their career and you know she tells
joe she hates him but forgives him and
she quotes proverbs to tell this episode
and you know wisdom if god can forgive
you then i can and then anyone can so
this will be the catalyst though for joe
to want to stop drinking and go to an
aaa meeting and that joe was set up as
his character it's supposed to be like
this mess you're not supposed to like
and that you like him as it goes on his
kind of redemption arc and how he gets
screwed by people like beverly who are
supposed to help people like joe but you
see bev is pushing religion in this
public school sheriff is not having it
so ali brought a bible home so bev won't
even listen to a word he says and even
when he tries to relate islam to
christianity she doesn't care for it she
doesn't even listen to what this dude
says
and it's a scene to show how much like a
hypocrite you know certain religious
people are and you know the thing is
though this scene did feel drawn out it
was long it just keeps going you know we
got the point of the scene about three
minutes in but bev just keeps ranting on
and on just tighten it up you know
the whole purpose of the scene is served
way quicker and it decides not to it
decides to double up here which i don't
get like you're seeing lines they throw
in like yes like she's using these
miracles to justify her belief being
pushed on everybody in the town but you
could do it quicker it's just so long
and you're seeing millie is saying to
sarah that she feels like she's been
somewhere dark but feels like she just
woke up and there you are sarah so it's
really her dementia going away and her
whatever mental illnesses she has
clearing up which i like i like how they
wrote that and like i said my criticism
of flanagan just keeps coming back here
where after we see father paul has this
meeting with riley and you know it's
setting up that paul's getting more
sicker and a little more jonesing for
blood here they switched into this
walking scene again with aaron and riley
it's just so much walking and talking
and you know he's tightening these
relationships and giving us reflective
talk that's really talking about themes
of the show but it's so
much and it's i'm really gonna lay into
it in an episode i hated which is coming
up but it's really showing here too
where like i think the main problem i
have with scenes like this with flanagan
is he writes his characters like they're
all poets and unlike socrates and that
they're philosophers and that that you
start getting out of it because you're
like
you still have to write it like the
character you know you can't just write
this amazing it's amazing writing like
if you're maybe reading it in a poem but
it doesn't work when your characters are
all talking like that like it's too much
it's almost like maybe this will work
better in a play you know where you're
in one location but it's not reliant on
visual storytelling where you got to
make it more interesting or you people
are just going to get bored it's
demanding the audience to just listen
and listen and listen and use their own
imagination where i think people when
they watch tv
they want to be given a little more
visual stimulation here because it is
boring and i think where people get
frustrated at this point is when we see
the sheriff and his young boy ali you
know talking about him wanting to be
christian
it becomes like 7th heaven the show like
melodrama at points where you're at that
point kind of wondering like you know
where is the horror you know and then
right on cue there is actually a jump
scare at the end of this scene but you
know there's points i do like in this
scene like i do like the moment the
sheriff talks about he hopes god doesn't
just pick and choose miracles that's not
how god works he says to his son talking
about lisa that's not magic but again
it's just so much leaning towards that
melodrama of the show that i wish he
would just make those scenes tighter and
a little less and give us a little more
of the horror we know he's good at so we
get to see now another good closing
scene of an episode where paul actually
dies in front of bev sturge the mayor
and the mayor's wife and he gets
resurrected here so they they know
what's up you know they know who this is
now and we know as the audience that he
is actually monsignor pruitt i love the
scenery here when he goes the ancient
ruin again powerhouse performance by
amish link later and you really see
sounding like taking on the role like
he's jesus in a way and he's gonna save
all these people on the island but we
learn later on to his real core
intention here bringing this demon back
to the island which he's still calling
an angel in his ignorance right that it
has to be a holy angel it can't be
something evil right because it made him
young again and that he wants a second
chance really out of life with sarah and
millie and that he doesn't want millie
to die so that this is a chance for like
avoiding death which they set up well
too which we'll get to with lines that
pruitt has to riley here and that he is
really in the day terribly afraid of
death because what happened to his
sister which i'm gonna hold on that but
we'll get to but it was really set up
well with that however i do think in
hiding some of these twists that we
needed a little more moments of
emotional connection between maybe
pruitt and millie that i would really
buy that that was his main intention at
the end and that maybe that came a
little rushed where all of a sudden was
revealed he was doing everything for
them like i don't know i i don't know if
that was totally earned and given enough
time i'm still tossing and turning about
that but i do that like they did this
slow pulling to the old newspaper of
young pruitt here again a great last
ending scene in a rather you know
painfully slow episode shows the best
and worst of flanagan in this episode
for sure again you have great ending
moment like this and but you got a lot
of melodrama that's just way too long so
first watch i actually gave this one 8.4
and second watch i brought it down a bit
8.1 i think it's just less enjoyable as
a whole but maybe that's because you
already know the twist watching it again
so i'd say it averages around you know
8.4 for sure but we'll stick with 8.1
because of the slowness i i still can't
get over that how slow some of those
scenes were okay so episode four
lamentations is my least favorite
flanagan episode if anything's ever done
this is gonna pass the jolly corner for
me which i didn't like in blind manor
this would be the second episode of
plans i don't like this one i actually
thought was pretty bad and i have a lot
of reasons for that one it's obviously
way over long it's an hour and nine
minutes long just too long and also
again just to point out it's directed by
mike flynn again it's written by
flanagan and danny parker here but you
know this opening scene i'm going to say
something's not a popular opinion i am a
huge fan of kate siegel who plays aaron
right but this is not her best acting in
this show and this scene in particular
was really let down for me when she
finds out she lost her kid and
miscarried but i don't fully blame him
on kate segal i think she was miscast
here that's the unpopular opinion i'm
gonna have i think kate siegel i'm not
trying to typecast her but she's so
talented that you know she needs to play
characters to me that have a little more
like rough around the edges and more
excitement to them this is more of the
plain character in in uh erin that you
can kind of cast a more safer actress
here where she's someone i feel like
she's being wasted but also it's almost
like underneath her and that she doesn't
i don't know if it's not it's not even
overacting it's just that it just
doesn't feel like it's her ballpark like
i don't know something simple scene like
this even where most actors can pull
this off she just seemed like a deer in
headlights which i thought was
disappointing i don't even know what i'm
really saying about it but again the
other day i think she's miscast here
that maybe this was a role better for a
victoria pedretti who was in blind manor
or you could find different actors who
would play that type of part but i just
don't think kate segal is that type of
actress and where it gets a little silly
too and like you know i feel like flanny
can get a little sappy and corny is like
why do they have to keep mentioning the
baby's name his little foot just you
know stop saying it it was the nickname
was just corny and there is this
monologuing that happens with aaron and
riley that is so long a couple times
this episode when they're on that couch
i get it's important you know to set up
their big moment that's great in episode
five but oh my god this was like
ridiculously long i said this in blind
manner there was a monologue like this
where you're just like i can't believe
what i'm watching how long this is and
again exposing like i'm saying he's
writing these characters talking like
poets like they all have a you know huge
iq on philosophy that i'm just not
buying it and you know they're talking
about what happens when you die here and
i think it really works for riley's
thematically but it gets a little corny
here with aaron's character
talking about where her lost child might
go when she dies her view of god and
heaven it's a little corny okay i'm
sorry flanagan it's corny like at the
end of the day you can find this in
hallmark channel stuff i know that's a
harsh criticism but it's the way it's
presented he is at his best when he's
presenting great messages in the
wrapping paper that's more interesting
of horror right but just having people
talk on a couch for so damn long you
can't tell me if you're in a living room
with five people that four of them
aren't gonna look at each other and be
like how long is this scene what why is
this so boring so i'm sorry i just don't
think it's great you get payoff for it
sure but you go through a lot of
suffering to get there so i just think
it needs to be tightened up that's all
i'm saying and you gotta write your
characters talking like actual people
here not just again talking like they're
writing some great writing it is good
writing but
come on i'm not i'm not buying how it's
getting presented so the tragedy though
of joe's story here is he chooses not to
drink which is the right thing to do
when he's really tempted right and
because of this he goes to pruitt and if
he did drink the ironic thing is he
would have not got killed by pruitt that
night if he had fallen to presentation
but by doing the right thing he actually
got himself killed and you see that
opposite effect where pruitt fell into
his temptation by killing joe and
mauling him i like how they wrote that
scene though and how he's like i know
that compulsion hunger how hard is to
fight against before he actually kills
him and it's really him talking about
himself it was nice writing there and
again like i said how much ling leader
any scenes with him are great he he just
is a presence so what i do love about
how they made this character of bev is
that she sees that joe's been killed
she's literally poisoned a dog but she
finds justification for everything for
her cause for her plan and she just
finds a bible verse every time to
justify our actions how many people have
we met in life just like bev who do this
and they do it such a good job and
that's such a props to the writing team
and research done for this show that
they found so many accurate bible verses
to match what's happening in the show
like a ridiculous amount so that had to
be so hard to find all those and they
did like nailing it out of the park with
that and samantha slowing again i can't
praise her enough how well she did this
character of beverly it's important here
though pruitt does not feel guilt keep
that in mind which will get to an
important scene what i also had a
problem with the writing here is that
when riley gets suspicious in the aaa
meaning of why joe isn't there he gets
suspicious like hardcore
of pruitt like it's a given because
pruitt says joe's visiting his sister
but it's just a priest saying that in
front of of riley like why would riley
take that as a given that that would be
a total lie that he's hiding something
why wouldn't he just maybe think like
you know the guy doesn't know what he's
talking about like i thought that was a
stretch to have the reason to ha get
riley to back to the rec center so we
can see his character get killed but it
just didn't make sense like he even says
to his mom i know for a fact father paul
lied to me tonight again i'm not buying
that that would just be something you
would think as riley like he's clearly
lying and doing something malicious i
think it was more of like okay he might
have just thought this guy had a sister
like that's what i would have thought
like why are we taking that as like this
huge possible plan i thought that was a
stretch to be the reason for the writers
to get riley to the rec center it was a
cool moment though when this demon
vampire launches at riley but like i
said this is my least favorite episode
of flanagan's resume first watch i gave
a 7.1 second watch 6.1 i again like i
said didn't like it that much again just
a lot of writing miscues to me and
those scenes on the couch my god
so episode five book five gospel this
was directed by mike flanagan but
written by mike and james flanagan now
what's crazy you know is i get mad at
him the last episode but then i love
this episode this is my favorite episode
of the series you totally redeem
yourself i will say though what wasn't
great about this episode was the
beginning because like again it's
setting up everyone's missing like
riley's missing joe's missing bowl's
missing which i like but you know it's
12 minutes of everyone catching up the
sheriff here so again it's info the
audience already knows catching up
characters there's got to be a way to
tighten this up and make it more
interesting but once it gets cooking you
know we get to this good friday night
mask this is where i'm like okay here we
go and you got you know gospel means
good news pruitt says and he talks about
jesus suffering enduring alone for
eternal life it's nicely again
connecting current situation with these
bible verses and he's saying god then
has an army which is a nice set up to
his plan and what he's doing here and
he's talking it like it's his troops
here like he's the commander and he's
like god will ask horrible things of you
the gospel lord so full of horror is
only good because of where it is headed
the resurrection again showing you
insight to his plan welcome to god's
army we're going to do great things just
great escalation of a character and
betrayal here by hamish linklater you're
watching like i don't know anyone else
who could have done this role so just
accurately as a priest and with such
nuance so riley here we'll see shows up
to aaron takes her on the boat but it's
beautifully setting up him staring at
the stars and moonlight riley's dream is
now coming to life that he had and he's
like riley's like a man of science
because he's really saying stuff like
everything started from the stars so he
then proceeds to tell everyone what
happened and now we'll see it as the
audience what i loved even just the
start of this flashback of right after
riley was killed by this vampire is that
we get to hear pruitt tell his trauma
and we're really getting to his
character now his sister died at the age
of eight of polio he's like i was
terrified of death that's what brought
me to god so i love they threw lines
like this in to really get why he is the
way he is and he's like i was trying to
understand how her death could be a part
of god's plan it's also giving you
sympathy here for pruitt as he's
snapping riley's neck into place so it's
a nice blend of r here and he's like god
still has a plan and death isn't a part
of it not for all of us we don't have to
be afraid ever again i love this line
it's so essential to his character and
that you know he was driven by that to
like think wow you know death's gone
this is the miracle put these blinders
on right and that ignorance that gets
ironically everybody killed like it's
showing you he had a good intention here
that went haywire and this was like
possibly my favorite scene where we get
now just a master class in writing and
acting from homici link later and
obviously from zach gilford and the
writing by flanagan his brother here and
the way pruitt reveals to riley who he
really is is perfect through the story
of when he was a boy riley and he gave
him this dying mouse he switched it out
just to give the boy some faith and he's
talking to him like i said how they set
us up where he's like the jesus figure
talking to this person who's now his
apostle he's trying to get from someone
who was a non-believer and he's like
look you're your peak self i'm at my
peak self just as god wanted but this is
where pruitt's not seeing what's really
happening here and riley is or pruitt's
like you came back to the rec center
like it was a calling but he really came
because he was concerned about joe and
that pruitt was lying and i love how
riley here is just going at him like the
truth of the situation that you killed
joe but brilliantly they use his
serenity prayer as a justification for
his behavior pruitt like accept things
we cannot change and you see they even
bring in beverly into this scene which
was just great again letting these
actors and actresses just act like
incredible stuff masterful work here and
this is where flanagan's at his best
it's like he's an actor's director he
gets the best performances out of people
and excellent cinematography in the
scene setting the mood as well and you
see riley's calling him a murderer but
he's like i felt no guilt you know
finding grace where the guilt should be
bev who's of course the one who showed
him the bible passes to justify this
he's like it cleans our conscience so
that we may serve the living god i did
his will been his vessel a murderer
maybe but so is moses so there's always
some kind of justification but it goes
back to what riley had said in that
previous scene that it's just using
faith as an excuse strong theme of the
show but you see pruitt pulls into riley
or saying he also killed someone but
it's the perfect moment to see the main
difference in these two characters that
you know riley sees it as what it is
it's ordinary what happened there's
nothing else to it again it's a very
jack shepherd john locke esque scene and
i love this moment where he asked riley
how it makes him feel that he had no
guilt after watching himself kill joe
how does it make you feel first says
angry then he says disgust nice is
jealous this was just incredible acting
by homage link later and zach gilford
amazing you understand bruce trying to
give him this like free ticket out of
the guilt for his
plan but riley is our hero because he
doesn't take that route what this
episode masterfully does it shows you
two men in a similar situation one
reacting in the heroic justified way
which we can appreciate which is riley
and pruitt acting in this ignorant way
riley takes the realistic approach and
is actually facing what really happened
here knowing he's a danger and he's
protecting aaron and his family from
himself and like i said the opposite is
the tragedy here of pruitt where he does
the opposite ends up getting all these
people killed which he will realize but
too late and what i love these little
lines like bev gives him the blood to
drink pruitt says it's okay this is one
of those things that can't be changed
accepted with wisdom and grace this is
exactly what riley does but not in the
way pruitt does like he's accepting yeah
you're right this can't change so i'm
gonna get
myself out of this island from hurting
people and protect the ones i love and
bev was actually in true fill and
fashion he was actually right to be
worried about riley leaving here and
this is where pruitt almost had too much
faith that you know hurt him in the end
letting riley go and i love how they
visually showed riley seeing what is
happening at the church finds his
purpose now his calling leaves notes for
his family and he's about to get to
errands he looks up at the stars this
was beautiful this is kind of showing
you i think flanagan's belief on
everything looking at just like the
universe as a whole guiding him there is
some type of faith there but it's more
grounded and what i love when we get
back on the boat and present day with
riley and aaron it's a nice misdirect
that you know you think he might bite
aaron here and they even play it like
that because there's a heartbeat sound
playing the temptation is there that's
what's reaffirming and it's showing you
the good and riley that he does have a
choice here even though he's tempted
he's holding away from hurting her and
that's why it's such a great line with
aaron here saying i'm not scared of you
because she knows how good riley is it
really shows that true love between them
and this scene's just beautiful i mean
it starts dark then slowly the sun's
starting to rise and he's like i love
yarn green and she says i love you too
and he's like i did my best as the sun
comes up and audio cuts perfectly and
you see the girl he killed but all in
white it's a beautiful moment she's
happy he doesn't have that guilt anymore
there's an acceptance there's growth
here it's full circle for his character
and she offers his hand to him ultimate
redemption for riley here and he knew
aaron had to see him get roasted to
believe this crazy story of vampires and
it's the true horror here that blends
with the beautiful moment this is
flanagan at his most most best i want
more of this and the crying over the
credits wow i was also crying over the
credits as was aaron he always gives you
a big episode flanagan that's what i
love about him and you know this is
right up there with bent neck lady in
hill house and the altar of the dead in
bly so first watchers was a 9.1 second
watch 9.6 this was gold now episode six
book six acts of the apostles was
directed by mike flanagan written by
mike and james flanagan with also jeff
howard here so i feel like this will be
a fan favorite i liked it a lot first
watch i think it has that effect but
second watch i didn't enjoy it as much
and i have my reasons but i think this
will be the fan favorite because this is
when [ __ ] hits a fan people love that
stuff uh because it's a big event
midnight mass right title the show here
and you see there's a big moment in the
beginning here where pruitt has
self-doubt because he knows riley didn't
go along with the plan it's showing in
his face but beverly you know just
pushes encourage him to keep going evil
beverly and she's like there will always
be a judas you know always has the line
for everything here and the big moment
like i said is ed giving pruitt this
letter from riley remember we are
dustin's to dust we shall return love it
another scene that just didn't work for
me with flanagan this is his like
achilles heel is when the sheriff
decides just to tell
this doctor sarah his whole backstory of
his time struggling being a muslim in
the police force and his wife dying
again it's that poet thing i'm talking
about or he's talking like a poet and
what i didn't like is i would have
actually appreciated this more for his
character in a bigger moment than just
in this random moment where sarah's
talking to him it feels like random as
hell for her to be the one that he's
telling us to like okay thanks guy but
like i i okay like you know it's it's a
giant answer for why he doesn't want to
investigate st patrick's as someone he
probably barely knows so i thought that
was like okay like
really forced in i don't mind what
they're writing here but do it in a
bigger moment for the sheriff not just
when he's talking to someone who's a
stranger to him now sturge cuts the
power i really liked everyone singing
with the candles on the way to mass
hypes it up it's very cool it's a very
cool visual thing here with the
candlelit mass again mike knows his
catholicism it feels like a real easter
night mass to open the set it's
beautiful the lighting here is perfect
and pruitt confesses his lie who he
really is to everybody and bev has all
this poison now in the cups it's like
this jonestown drink the kool-aid moment
here and a big moment i liked here was
the sheriff having to watch his son
drink this poison that really worked and
he's like i chose god and that will get
paid off later so that story wrapped
well i feel like and that starts here
and the big moment here where bev really
does an awful choice is letting everyone
out even against pruitt wishes where
pruitt wanted everyone to be guided
first before they were let out she's
just awful and she's like even quoting
pruitt herself saying how else does the
gospel spread but first watch this
episode you know i gave it a 9.1 but
second watch 8.6 because it really if
you watch it again it's not great until
the last 20 minutes in this big midnight
mass otherwise you know you feel a
little bit of riley missing for a bit
here and it kind of becomes the three
team with millie aaron and sarah just
trying to plot everything out which can
be a little tedious and kind of
something you've seen a million times
before so i felt like it did lose its
footing a bit but i will say again with
the redeeming self you know flanagan
here he wrote and direct the finale i
love the finale in blind manner and
guess what i love the finale here in
episode seven book seven revelation so
you see millie she resurrects after
getting attacked by this demon she's
fully youthful now and she sits with
pruitt in the church and i really like
how this whole story went the finale and
what i loved about this finale it really
wraps every character's story really
well prue confesses to millie here you
know about what his plan was and sarah
was the reason he brought the angel here
and her not wanting to die and he's like
you and her daughter never felt like a
sin never a mistake and millie's like
she grew up and we fade away that's how
it's supposed to work it's supposed to
be over and that's you know pruitt's
downfall was trying to beat death here
it's the miracle pruitt wanted to happen
in that drive for that that selfish need
really at the end of the day hurt
everybody else and he just wanted
another chance that we could be a family
this time it's tragic you know and it
worked well and this is an example where
the sap works like it's just the right
amount of time in this dialogue this is
what you need to do flanagan right here
it's like a five minute scene with them
talking about it good doesn't need to be
15 minutes and the characters sound like
how they would talk so good and even
annie and ed here they're both turned to
vampires but they're both starving but
they can resist the urge i like this and
ed's saying whatever this is it doesn't
change who you are it's true to this
family the flins it's what riley did
it's what they do they resist that
temptation where someone like pruitt
could not and you see the change here
for pruitt's character that comes around
here for his ark that he says to bev we
got this wrong we are the wolves and
he's sounding like riley now which is is
that growth right and beb even has a
bible verse here against priests and
scribes at this moment but she's really
heartbroken by this and that's shown so
well here by samantha sloane like this
was something you could really see her
be crushed by i love the touch too where
when pruitt tells sarah the truth about
him being the father of her right before
she's about to burn the church
she gets shot what i love is when pruitt
tries to give her blood to resurrect her
she spits it out that's such a big
moment that little thing it's such a
nice touch the difference of a character
sarah being one of our heroic characters
making the choice not to just take that
easy way out because she knows you know
you're gonna hurt people that way but i
love too when the sheriff is here in
front of beverly before he's shot by
beverly he says a verse from the bible
that stuck with me he makes the sun rise
on the evil and the good which will
happen but it's it's foreshadowing that
i've seen but i also love that his son
he got to see his son before he got shot
make the right choice and burn the rec
center and i thought that was excellent
that's all the father won at the end of
the day what was right for his son and
aaron has this great moment when the
demon attacks her and kills her because
she cuts his wings again super heroic
this will really save everyone at the
end of the day because remember when
that demon now is flying away when
warren and liz are on the boat they
infer the demon won't make it past the
sunrise it could barely fly that's
because again aaron cut the wings and
you see even everybody in this crew that
beverly has made is starting to come
with their senses they're realizing what
they've done you know they're trying to
have forgiveness for each other and
realize how crazy saul is but bev never
comes to that you know she's
irredeemable she has no remorse and
aaron i really like this moment where
she thinks about a convo it's very meta
with her and riley here they're back on
this couch and it's like if she was
talking to him now and that self is the
problem every out of my body forced into
a star there's no me there never was
there is no point where any of that ends
and i begin i am energy not memory not
self we are all one the cosmos dreams
that's god so this to me is flanagan
just speaking what he believes um you're
getting his view of death and the
universe here in god this is where i
would say that philosophical type of
monologue works because we're in this
kind of state of a rush of dmt and her
dying it works that the character would
talk like this in this dreamlike
sequence but you know it was it was
really good until one line here where
she says i am that i am sounds like dr
seuss i don't know what that was but
again it makes it all this like book of
flanagan it works except that one line
but that's me nitpicking and look you
see this right flannigan made this
mention you know everyone starts singing
how even the darkness and the worst of
an absolute light and hope we sing
that's flanigan's direct quote in his
letter about the show and it's just
beautiful shots here in particular
beverly on the beach looking at the
sunrise and across from her seeing
something she hates you know the sheriff
and her son doing their prayer and their
happiness in this moment and bev even
tried to dig herself you know just to
stay alive and wow i mean what a
beautiful moment the ashes of everyone
falling on lisa and warren here in the
boat and she says lion i can't feel my
legs
wow and they smile at this this was
incredible first watch for me was 8.2
but when you watch again it's such a
strong finale closing everything up
thematically and with characters i give
it a 9.4 and that line right like i
can't feel my legs now it's like showing
you this beauty and something that was
like looked as as a tragedy and now that
like she's happy it's that way that all
this stuff that was supposed to be way
out these miracles wasn't the way you
know and it just comes around like that
beautifully and it's like wow that's the
relief now that's to write that
situation that you're relieved now that
you can't feel your legs is like
something else by the writing there for
flanagan so bravo so i averaged all my
scores this time for each episode i'm
gonna average the second watch scores
because it's more recent in my head so
averaging all the scores out this season
will get a 8.4
so in my rankings of flanigan shows hill
house is a 9.4 average oil blind manners
8.7 averaged all out midnight mass is
8.4 so it does fall on the third tier
here for me but i mean when it hits
strong flannigan it's amazing he could
be the best of the best but when he goes
low here what i mean by that is like
that episode four it was torture and
it's so unfortunate because i think he's
getting in his own way and it's like
people who fight about blind man or
blind manner was very divisive as hill
house was kind of praised altogether
which is rightfully so what hill house
does differently than blind manner and
midnight mass is
it was able to keep things moving it had
more horror in it but it blended the two
genres well and like i said with heavy
themes of flanny where he gets happy he
had a nice wrapping of horror in it
where sometimes he lets it go full sap
in blind manor he does it here again and
again just over long scenes where
characters are written not believably
how they're talking like i said like
poets it's such a crutch that he's got
to get over and he's got to tighten
things up to get back to the hill house
level but i overall enjoyed it and i get
people who you know most most viewers
casual viewers are going to watch this
they're going to be bored out of their
minds at episode 4 and probably stop
watching so it's frustrating because it
stops you know from people really
getting the core and the awesome moments
and flanagan's got to work on that
that's a problem you know you got to
make it a little more enjoyable first
watch and you can't just say i'm doing
you're getting through this you're going
to get rewarded but give us more reward
in the end because people stop watching
so i think that's a big problem and it
needs to be fixed you can get
pretentious as you want in the comments
and say oh those are just stupid people
watching but no i mean it's got to be
entertaining sorry like it has to be so
blended right haunting fieldhouse did
that where blind manor and midnight
mouse struggle in that department but
again
with everything that's coming out it's
still one of the better shows on
flanagan super talented and props
especially i'm going to say to zach
gilford homicide glader and samantha
sloan here
brilliant performances i mean they're
all knocked out of the park where i
usually locate siegel i think she missed
a mark here but i'm going to give half
that credit due to bad casting that she
was miscast as this part let me know you
thought of it down below i love to hear
your thoughts i read every comment try
to respond as many as i can if you love
what i do here i really appreciate if
you sign up to be a member you can
donate it will help me do this full time
and do more reviews for you guys i
really really appreciate that you get
perks as well so check that out please
follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock as well
for more shorter reviews and celebrity
interviews they do as well so you want
to check those out and i'll see you next
time